hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today we continue our series looking at
the voice actors behind the characters
in your favorite video games this
episode is dedicated to death stranding
one of 29 teams most anticipated titles
which has one of the strangest
storylines in videogame history but
we'll look at that in another video
today we celebrate the awesome actors
behind those heroes and villains and
look at where you may recognize many of
them from so if you're ready let's do
this the only place we can start is with
Sam bridges played by Norman Reedus
start yet maybe you are defective
for ten seasons now we've known him as
Darrell from The Walking Dead a
motorcycle-riding crossbow wielding
zombie slayer we go get your man back
kill negan take out his voice will you
hook us up
but do you recognize him from more than
this well Norman has been acting since
the early 1990s here's one I found from
back in the day it's a biak music video
from so far back we didn't have HD and
we didn't have widescreen either though
those are bad times
everything was square this is violently
happy in the video he can be seen
hacking off his own hair lovely but my
favourite Norman Reedus moment comes in
a Marvel film from back before Marvel
films were called to be in back in 2002
Norman played Scud in Blade - he was a
tech expert for the daywalker he is his
best bit and then spoiler alert bombs a
dud was never supposed to explode mister
supposed to make you feel in control
great man I love that film and after all
that Norman became Sam and carried dead
people as a post-apocalyptic postman
how times change on the other side of
the spectrum is the villain of the piece
this is Higgs played by the legend that
is Troy Baker you see her truth is I
don't much care for my face that's why I
hide it those of you who played video
games regularly are guaranteed to know
his voice
he's been heard in seemingly hundreds of
video games
Troy has voiced some legendary
characters along the way including my
personal favorite Joel from the Last of
Us franchise insert epic Joel moment
here
[ __ ] you Dylan keep walking a sickie
block where's Aubrey we're top floor the
far end
other videogame characters played by
Troy Baker include Batman in the Lego DC
games
Aaron Black in mortal kombat Magni in
god of war and sound drake in uncharted
oh and us in row in the infamous series
yeah who told that hurts
honestly this guy has such an impressive
CV a truly great resume from a truly
great voice actor and looking into 2020
Troy will voice Bruce Banner in Marvel's
Avengers hi I'm Troy Baker and I play
Bruce Banner Troy is a busy boy my name
is fragile yeah I've heard that right
our next character is fragile played by
Lisa Dhulia is a French actress who gets
many English speaking parts starting
back in 2004 leah has slowly been
climbing the roster the ranks to lead
movies resulting in repeated roles in
the James Bond film Spectre and no time
to die and she's also played Sabine in
Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol but
her breakout role is playing Emma in
blue is the warmest color and now Leah
fills the boots of fragile and eats
insects for fun
yeah this star is weird a crypto buy it
a day keeps the time fall away
one of the headline actors of death
stranding is none other than the legend
that is Mads Mikkelsen proving once
again video games are a legitimate
contender to Hollywood movies even home
space and second all this is over take
you wherever you want to go max plays
the games which we call it enigma
Clifford Unger
I see Mads most days on the TV in
adverts and commercials trying to sell
me alcohol whilst riding a bike probably
but his acting resume goes much deeper
than that
his most notorious role came in 2013
when he played dr. Hannibal Lecter in
the TV adaptation of the movies there we
go Mads is another actor in death
stranding to feature in a Bond film
plane Latifah in Casino Royale but you
were so wrong because even after I
slaughtered you and your little
girlfriend your people would still
welcome me with open arms other
impressive appearances include Draco in
Clash of the Titans the accountant in a
Rihanna music video that's true and the
antagonist in the Doctor Strange film
but to me he'll always be a dude on a
bike they say that we Danes are the
happiest nation in the world next on our
death stranding hit list is someone you
may not know the site of but he's a big
deal in the movie industry
this is Guillermo del Toro who plays
dead man humanity's best hope for the
future or avoiding the extinction if you
prefer right the reason you may not know
Guillermo is because he usually stands
behind the camera he writes directs and
produces movies in fact we have a link
to him and Norman Reedus as del Toro
directed late to the movie when Norman
exploited
Guillermo also directed Pacific Rim and
Pan's Labyrinth and he was scheduled to
be a large part of the silent hill's
video game before Konami ditched that
project as a writer he penned many
screenplays which became huge hit movies
such as The Hobbit but I think I should
probably stop talking about my love of
Guillermo del Toro in the game del Toro
plays dead man but did you know that he
didn't mocap it and he doesn't voice it
either that was by another performer but
his voice was so close it completely
fooled me Gigi
fYI dead man's voice is created by Jesse
corty who is yet another voice actor in
so many video games it's frightening
just cause for Red Dead Redemption 2
uncharted 3 and the sublime Metal Gear
Solid Peace Walker but the one which
made me Yelp with excitement was this
Jesse played Reptar in the Rugrats
what a claim to fame please tell me
you're old enough to remember that in
fact let's just move on do you recognize
this actress this is Lindsay Wagner who
is 70 years old but she doesn't look a
day over 23 Lindsay plays both the aging
President of the USA Bridget strand and
her daughter Amelie to play the younger
character Lindsay's likeness from the TV
series The Bionic Woman
and before that the Six Million Dollar
Man from back in 1979
Lindsay's career is about to spanned six
decades I could not imagine working that
long gg's Lindsay most recently she can
be spotted playing Helen Karev in Grey's
Anatomy
based on Lindsay Wagner's voice Emily O
Brien helps out so she too has a credit
here just as an FYI our next character
is Hartman who in the game has a heart
which stops every 21 minutes that's
death stranding in a nutshell
well you certainly caught me with my
pants down glad you could make it Sam
Hartman is played by Darren Jacobs who
is primarily a voice actor that assists
in movies for example he's a commentator
in the recent Ford vs. Ferrari and lends
his vocal talents too many Marvel films
including Captain Marvel and guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 and most recently
he's worked on the men in black
international film quite a change from
his soap opera days plane Oliver Graham
in Hollyoaks
so there's a guy in death stranding with
a cool mask it's it's beautiful I made
by one this is die hard Minh played by
Tommy Earl Jenkins stop listen to me
America needs you both of you covering
the world in cable didn't bring an end a
warrant suffering
Tommy started his acting career back in
the 1990's and has been seen on TV video
games and movies his acting credits
include fallout 76 but we do not talk
about that dumpster fire here and on TV
he voices you'll be corn on the go
Jettas I still remember the day I beat
cadet glitch and set the Academy land
speed record he's likely best known
though for Ellison Penn V in the TV
series Pandora hmm I care about the
well-being of my client and preventing
her from serving the next 20 years in
jail for crimes she didn't commit so
there we have it those are some of the
actors behind the great characters in
death stranding have you played the game
what do you think of it it took 20 hours
for me for it to click but once it did
Wow I'm addicted right now addicted
anyway I'm Adam from PlayStation granade
thank you for your time if I've missed
anything please let me know my name is
Adam grenade on Twitter Cheers see you
soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]